Suraj Kapoor is one of Britain's
best-known artists the sculptor made
this year's Sunday Times Rich List
without 175 million pound fortune but
he's also anxious about brexit and much
else in politics I spoke to him at the
unveiling of his latest exhibition at
London's listen gallery
I guess the current political atmosphere
generates anxiety and we all anxious is
an anxiety part of a certain
contemporary reality and of course as an
artist you can't avoid it it's one is
open to all these things work I'm
terribly anxious about India because
we're just in the middle of election and
the election results to be announced
soon we cannot carry on in this terrible
terrible tyrannical hinduist fashion
that's become you know Moody's signature
so I think that's a huge huge danger and
then great number of people are in
danger because of it lives and
livelihoods I'm anxious about brexit
because it says that at least
temporarily we don't know what we're
doing and how can Britain be in a state
where it's sort of wandering around like
this declaring all of us to each other
we don't know what we're doing terribly
difficult not for you and me perhaps
we're old guys but for a younger
generation who don't know what life will
bring and of course one has to be
anxious about the environment and
whether all these questions of what's
what what there is when we you know look
at those issues we've touched on brexit
BJP in India anti-semitism is the
problem perhaps that your world to a
certain extent lesser extent the world
are I'm having over
hello globalized elite is it's just
what's getting up people's noses which
is why they are reaching for these
divisions so you start leader picked it
I mean I think increasingly we have to
be sophisticated and say to ourselves
that I have the way I describe it to
myself I have one leg in my local
situation whatever it is I'm Indian or
whatever else
Jewish whatever else one leg there and
the other leg in the world that makes me
cosmopolitan tells me that I'm rooted
here and able to function there that
gives us in my sense an open I like this
cosmopolitan idea that we are we share
now globalization clearly threatens many
of us partly because those who have have
more and those who don't have don't have
and that's the real problem is that we
have an increasingly so divided the
world between you know I'm rich because
they're poor and that is a terrifying
terrifying thing that we have to correct
so again to go back to brexit it's
austerity that made brexit that's why we
are where we are I mean you are very
rich or this suddenly does richness a
fairly well I'm not gonna pretend
otherwise you know the world's been good
to me or life's been good to me but that
does not mean that I don't recognize
that there is huge huge separation
between those who have and those who
don't have and the world is owned by
those who have because they don't have
so and I'll give it away if that's what
you are you well I'll work at it I'll
try and do it in the right way it's very
very difficult thing to do even that and
I mean the mood certainly is very
different from when you did the the
orbit sculpture and the Olympic Park
isn't it it is it is that was some it
was a time of can do must do will do
Britain
and now we are blindly looking through
it through a mesh I'm sure there's a way
out